hallo mein name ist klug und ihr habt
nicht wahrscheinlich schon sehr lange
nicht mehr in dieser position hier
gesehen wir spielen heute zusammen gold
simulator nach einer sehr langen zeit
habe ich mir gedacht die spiel mal
wieder dieses spiel
die ziege ist wieder komplett am arsch
ich weiß die steuerung gar nicht mehr
richtig ja genau so
diese ziege ist echt irre alter ich
hatte einfach den kompletten september
frei blöde hielt hatte den kompletten
september frei jetzt gerade ist ja auch
schon ende september und deswegen weiter
halten hatte die ganze zeit mit meiner
familie das wird jetzt allerdings ändern
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht um
langsamer wieder so einen diese gaming
auf coole sache auf einem kanal
reinzukommen mein gott ich hatte einmal
wieder bock auf gold simi deswegen bis
hochgeladen befinde mich jetzt gerade
irgendwo auf einem berg die bin ich
hierhergekommen bin ich hierher gekommen
ich hab sie mir jetzt locker drei vier
monate nicht mehr regelmäßig hochgeladen
deswegen schreibt mir mal bitte einfach
in die kommentare ob ihr das feiert und
zweitens viel wichtiger was da alles so
neu dazu gekommen ist weil ich spiele
jetzt gerade diese standard map hier
wieder aber da gibt es ja mittlerweile
auch komplett neue welten also ich habe
ja auch schon diese pay day sache sehr
oft hochgeladen und auch diese andere
welt am strand habe ich ja auch schon
öfters mal gemacht was ich gerade
allerdings nun möchtest auf diese trampe
menschen stecke ich gerade im boden
also wenn man andere youtuber
golfsimulator spielen ist es ja meistens
mit ihnen der story verbunden bei mir
sieht das ganze dann so aus geht's dir
gut zu ihr ich drücke die ganze zeit
leertaste laufe wie sonst was aber es
passiert einfach gar nix ich glaube ich
muss das ganze mal ganz kurz neu starten
ein paar schicken den später ich habe
meine andere ziele hier mit im
schlepptau und wir werden das ganze
jetzt noch mal probieren da oben hoch zu
kommen zu dem trampolin weil ich war ja
schon lange
ich mir unterstanden irgendwie zwei
leute die mir ein bisschen suspekt
vorkamen euro was ist denn hier passiert
ist hier etwa einen tank mit bak
das ist ein fucking ich tief mit bei
euch was passiert eigentlich wenn man
diesen tunnel bis zum ende reichte
traveller ok wo ich bin jetzt einfach in
der area raus kommen wo ich schon mal
war
was ist das da oben für ein mensch war
mir tatsächlich schon des öfteren in
dieser welt und sie habe ich ja auch
schon mehrere dezimeter videos
hochgeladen
ich checke jetzt aber mal ganz alles
klar anstatt es die ziegel der durch
springt einfach oben drüber obdach ich
lag die ganze die beteiligung an und
nimmt hier vorne es irgendwie diese
komische person ich weiß nicht was ihr
hier macht ich weiß nicht ob er darunter
springen will oder ob er irgendwie so
minimal darunter schützen
ich tue mir spaß
wieso war es klar dass das passiert ich
meine wie sollten ziegen auch sonst
schwimmen als so so stimmt jede ziege
ich versuche jetzt einfach über das
trampolin irgendwie hier hoch zu kommen
also ich bin jetzt was soll das was
passiert wenn ich gegen da vorne hätte
ich hin muss
ich glaube ich bin aber ist ein ufo
meine damen und herren die ziege
schwimmt wieder ganz standardmäßig auf
das andere ufer springt hier kurz hoch
und wir laufen jetzt mal hier hinten hin
weil ich dort ja gerade ein ufo entdeckt
habe ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich
damit interagieren kann oder damit
irgendwas machen kann aber das finden
wir jetzt jeden moment heraus also hier
ist ein ufo und was ist das denn habe
ich in dieses ufo hier irgendwie rein
gehen oder muss ich mich hier einfach
irgendwie vielleicht hinlegen scheint
nicht zu bewirken ich weiß nicht warum
aber irgendwie habe ich einen riesigen
stein angelegt und bin jetzt ein halber
steinen hey leute was ihm einen stein
tränen von mir ich selber gar nichts
mehr wir haben immer noch den komischen
typen hier und schauen jetzt mal endlich
ob wir ihn dazu bewegen können das
am sorry ich kenne mich irgendwie
überhaupt nicht mehr aus mit dem spiel
ich weiß gar nicht was das hier alles
für menschen sind veranlasst was ich ja
alles tue und was es hier alles soll und
warum ist da oben helikopter der da
jetzt irgend wie oder was tut er was zum
fix ist dass hier hier sind mega viele
ziegen um gekommen seid ihr bereit für
die absolute gottex danke danke danke
danke meine damen und herren das war
echt super besser als tony hawk es
jemals hätte machen können aber ich bin
in godzilla doch eigentlich viel mehr
der radfahrer also ich komme damit gut
ich habe derzeit echt ein paar probleme
mit meinem leben und weiß echt ich wie
ich davon wegkommen soll es das was ihr
von dem video meine damen und herren es
euch gefallen hat würde ich mich über
eine bewertung freuen
hier findet hier vorne einen smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf die könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren und hier findet
ihr ein anderes video verlinkt liegt das
auf jeden fall mal alles auf jeden fall
auch mega cool geworden und dann sehen
wir uns im nächsten video wieder haut
rein